brad keller the opening day starter for
kansas city gets the ball for mike
matheny on the mount once again for
kansas city is right hander brad keller
two away runner at third base for omar
narvaez
pitch to narvaez swinging a line driving
the left of base hit narvaez comes
through and the brewers jump out in
front one nothing
not an easy thing by any stretch but
narvaez with a bleeding single in the
shallow left field the brewers have the
lead and now
abby garcia
brad at the belt checks the runner at
second brings it home ground ball that
looked like it skipped on second base
fielded by merrifield flips to lopez
force at second
on
vogelbach to end the inning
three hits in a run two left and after
half an inning milwaukee won the royals
are coming up burns was really good and
his return to the rotation last time out
against st louis only gave up one run
but struck out nine he was on a little
bit of a pitch count in that last
appearance now it's been intended
andrew's game-winning hit last night his
40th hit of the season he has three home
runs his batting average is 282.
pitch
struck him out 98 mile an hour fastball
off the plate two strikeouts and a
flawless first for corbin burns
off and running in kansas city
one-nothing brewers
the number nine hitter pablo reyes
milwaukee shortstop
here's nikki with a long throw on a
bounce and carlos santana has a nice
stretch
nicely done
so
an economy of pitches there very good
defense down go the brewers one two
three
the end of an inning and a half one to
nothing milwaukee that brings up michael
taylor
three balls two strikes on the royal
center fielder
cam gallagher on deck
pitch is made and it's hammered into
deep left center field by taylor and
gone michael taylor
on a 3-2 pitch
and puts the royals in front by one home
run number four for taylor
boglebach has faced
keller seven times in his career and has
four hits three of those home runs
here's the pitch a swing and a miss he
struck him out and brad keller really
bowed his neck and got the big out with
runners on the corners he strikes out
narvaez strikes out vogelbach we head to
the bottom of inning number three it's
the royals two and the brewers one and
there's one away now for whitmerfield
the 1-1 pitch ground ball gobbled up by
shy spins and throws to first that's a
tremendous play by travis shaw
and there's two away
hard hit ball off the bat of mere field
shaw moving to his right backhands it
spins the opposite way and makes a nice
throw to first
brings up jackie bradley jr
jackie two for his last 44
going back to that home run against the
dodgers on april 30th had that eight
game hitting streak earlier in the
season this is an important guy for the
brewers to get going he's had some big
swings this year for the brewers no
question but
overall it's been tough going he puts a
charge into this one deep right field
back and gone for jackie bradley jr
brewers need to get him going how about
that one
we're tied at two
got a slider
got out in front of it and jbj with home
run number four on the season
vogelback stands in left-handed hitter
now the payoff pitch
swing and the grounded to the right side
whit has it on the outfield grass he'll
fire to first and that will take care of
back
to our score
runner at third base only one out and
the batter is jackie bradley jr right
now the way this game's going and the
way milwaukee doesn't score many runs as
wet as the grass is i'm sending him on
contact
oh man that balls hit well to deep
center field taylor goes all the way
back and taylor makes the catch
oh man what a play the run will score
but michael a taylor
ran a mile and made the defensive play
of the year
he took a perfect route right to the
ball timing is everything timed it
perfectly didn't even look back to the
wall this
young man has got some skills
[Music]
oh look at that happy he made that look
so easy
oh that's a big pickup
brent's left one up now narvaez comes up
barlow to the plate a swing and a miss
he struck him out so the royals leave
yelich stranded at second base and we
head to the bottom of inning number
seven here at kauffman stadium milwaukee
leads it three to two
solaire's glad that burns is out of
there so are most of the royals so
they're popped to short and then burns
struck him out on three pitches in the
fourth inning
the 1-0 solaire bangs it hits it pretty
well that's real deep and that's a way
back and that's going to tie the game on
a long home run by jorge solaire
3-3 ball game
we've been waiting for the big guy to
heat up
his fourth home run has tied the game
got one in his wheelhouse and he
exploded on it
hitting it high and deep
and now the royals have the go ahead run
just 90 feet away with one out so now
the batteries nikki lopez the infield
will be in now nikki himself has five
sacrifices this year
and you've got that great speed over at
third
higher eisen with the pitch lopez gets
the bunt down they trying to shovel home
but safe is jarrod dyson as they throw
got away
and the royals take a 4-3 lead there you
are make them make a play
and now it's carlos santana here's the
2-0 to santana and it's
a one-hopper to long in the shift he'll
recover and throw to first in time after
he dropped it momentarily
and the inning is over
so fire eisen gives up a couple of runs
did a good job of limiting the damage
so now hanser alberto gets his first
plate appearance
here's a little
thumber out into shallow right field
salvi rounds third
wong throws to the plate salvi scores
alberto goes to second
and the royals lead by two in the eighth
inning
so two out runner at third
michael taylor at the plate
and taylor takes inside here comes
hamzer alberto he is in there
that is a heads up base running play on
ball four
and the royals have a three run lead in
the eighth inning
nikki
laid down a bunt and a squeeze play
and i've got dyson home in the seventh
inning that's one of the big plays of
the contest
it's been a tough sequence one two line
towards left coming on jackie bradley jr
and he makes a basket catch belt hide
and the inning finally
one away for colton wong
one one coming
long line drive right center field that
plugs the gap
cutting it off is dyson going from first
to third with ease is jackie bradley jr
now he's going to be sent around home
here's the throne not in time
it's a double for colts and wong
and the brewers are within a couple of
runs now
now the tying runs are on base
and narvaez is coming to the plate
and stomach gets a call third strike
so he wasn't at his best tonight but he
hung in there
and the royals sweep the two-game series
from the brewers